what is up everybody it's animak here
for
anime opera and today i will be talking
about one of the craziest reveals
in the history of black clover the
devious
devil makikula has finally appeared in
the flesh
and not only is she planning to kill
noel and a bunch of other important
characters
but she also might be planning something
behind lucifer's back
are there different factions forming
among the highest ranked
devils and could this be a major plot
point
after this arc ends let's get into it
if you enjoyed the blacklover videos on
this channel and you want to see more
just leave a like and comment it's quick
it takes like a second but it helps a
lot with the youtube algorithm
and if you're new to anime out pro or
maybe you watch our videos but you just
haven't taken the time to subscribe yet
do me a favor and make this the video
that you subscribe and hit
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications
it's annoying but you really have to go
through the trouble of subscribing
hitting the bell and then selecting the
option that says
all if you don't do that you're still
gonna miss a ton of our videos even if
you are subscribed it's just how youtube
works
finally this video will contain black
clover manga spoilers so please
proceed with caution you have been
warned okay so at the end of the
previous chapter
noel had once again stabbed vanica
this time with her new sword and the
implication was that noel had killed her
but as i said in my previous black
clover video we've had this same
scenario before
noel stabs vanica it seems like vanica
is fatally injured
but thanks to her devil powers vanica
manages to survive
something similar even happened during
her battle with ossier
all those years ago and yeah that is
pretty much what happened in the new
chapter at least at first
in my previous black clover video i said
that i think that veronica
will be defeated by noel and i said that
the next threat
would be manika's devil megikula herself
and the same goes for dante and xenon i
think they've outlived their usefulness
and the focus of the story will now
shift from the dark triad
to their devils in terms of anakin
megicula
that is exactly what happened in the
latest chapter
megicula herself emerged in the flesh
and she made it clear that her intention
is to sacrifice vanica
along with loro pachika in order to
fully manifest her own body
into this world and although we
technically didn't know megicula's
gender until now
this chapter pretty much confirms that
she is indeed female
in line with anime logic she seems to be
a thousand-year-old
lolly devil queen and she is both creepy
and kinda kawaii at the same time but
let's get back to the story
after getting stabbed by noel venica
takes her already raging yandere energy
to the next level she keeps screaming
about how this fight is fun and how noel
chan
is the best but noel still isn't having
any of it
while venica is doing all her yandere
crap noel just ruthlessly attacks vanica
over and over again noel is using the
sword in combination with some
incredible athletic abilities she's
straight up using gymnastics and like
ballet moves to beat the crap out of
vanica
eventually noel has vanica completely
pinned to the ground
and she declares that vanica has lost
noel's new power-ups combined with
spirit dive
were indeed able to take vanakkah down
vanika is now topless for some reason
man
tabitha is really going ham on this
fight no cap
no top nothing and of course vanika is
still as crazy as ever
in fact she goes into full himiko toga
mode
saying that now that she and noel had
had a few good fights they must be
friends veronica's all like okay this
was fun now i'll take some time to get
stronger like you did last time and then
we'll fight again it'll be so much fun
we'll be besties and rivals it's gonna
be great but
noelle just gives her the most fierce
look and she's like
yeah i don't think so you crazy ass
noelle says that vanica just
acts out of her own selfish interests
she treats
other people as objects for her own
amusement and noel wants nothing to do
with that
in fact noel as the true chadlace that
she is
prepares to finish manika off once and
for all
and honestly it is so refreshing to see
a hero in a manga
being willing to actually kill a villain
vernica is obviously an evil and
terrible person
someone who wants to kill off most of
humanity just for fun
and noel knows that if she doesn't kill
her venica will go on to hurt
many many innocent people noel
isn't pulling a deku or a goku and
trying to save everyone including the
villains
noel is willing to do what it takes to
protect the world from the likes of
annika
and that means putting vanica out of her
misery period and even though noel
doesn't get to actually finish manika
off due to a crazy twist that is about
to occur
i have to say that i respect her
willingness to do what needs to be done
for the greater good nevertheless just
before noel takes manika out for good
megicula herself emerges her dark
devil energy spews out of vanica and
engulfs noel
which stops her from finishing the job
mkikula declares that if
three souls of powerful mages who share
the same sex presumably the same sex as
her which is female
are sacrificed then she can manifest
fully
into this world and so megicula's plan
is to sacrifice vanika and laura pachika
in order to bring her true form into the
human realm
megicula's devil lolly form emerges from
vanica's body
and she kind of sits on vanica's
shoulder but
it appears that makikula is now fully in
control of anika
and she is simply using vanika as her
temporary connection to this world
until she can fully manifest on her own
megikula says that before she manifests
her real body
she is going to give us one final
rampage and in that moment we see that
poor lordo pechika has been completely
taken over by devil magic
and now has a devil form of her own loro
pechika is looking pretty hardcore goth
right about now and megicula says that
if vanica and larpachika die
then noel won't feel lonely when she
dies as well
and that is how this shocking chapter
ends
first up whoa it is so cool to finally
see megikula's true form
was i expecting her to be a kawaii devil
lolly no i was not but i have to say
that i do like her design
she also has four horns she has those
ram horns we saw
in the silhouette and she also has two
long sharp horns on the front of her
head near her forehead
i was just talking to my boy rtl faith
about this on twitter
and i don't know whether there is some
significance to the number of horns but
it seems that only magikal and lucifer
have four horns
in their base forms asta has four horns
in his double union mode and
knocked has four horns in his gallus x
felis double devil union mode but i
wonder if having four horns right off
the bat
has some sort of significance let me
know down in the comments
if you guys like this design and do you
think that this is her true form
or will magikula look different after
she is able to fully manifest
into this world also it's hard to tell
exactly what mcgill was saying about the
three same-sex mages being sacrificed
because i'm only going by the unofficial
translation the official translation on
viz.com should clear things up a bit and
i will address the official translation
in the next video
but from what we know so far either the
three sacrifices are referring to vanica
laura pacheca and noel herself or
megicula could be
already counting aussiea as one of the
sacrifices
since she was a powerful mage who died
because of megicula's curse
only much much earlier if aussie
accounts then megikula only needs to
sacrifice vanika and laropachika
if ossier doesn't count then she also
needs to sacrifice noel or maybe
charlotte
but i don't see either noel or charlotte
actually die
so if mkikula needed either one of them
to die she's probably not going to
succeed with her plan
frankly knowing tabitha i don't even
think that laura pechika will die
but manika i could totally see being a
sacrifice
and the same goes for dante and xenon so
we'll have to wait and see what happens
at any rate we need to talk about the
game-changing implications of makikula
revealing herself like this
we didn't even know that this type of
manifestation was possible
and it seems that not even lucifer knew
about it despite being one of the
highest ranked devils
so why did mcgill imply that not even
lucifer knows this
we know that lucifer has been attempting
to fully manifest into the physical
world for a long time
so was makikula hiding this information
from him on purpose
if she was it suggests that there might
be some tension and even rivalry
among the highest devils and there might
even be some different factions among
the devils that we still don't know
about
in that case it would make for some
interesting material in the ark that
will eventually
follow the spade kingdom war arc i
always kind of assume that lucifer was
the main devil
because the underworld in black clover
is heavily inspired by
dante's inferno and of course lucifer is
the devil at the very bottom of dante's
inferno he
is the big boss however we know that
three different devils rule over the
underworld and who knows maybe those
three devils have different ideas about
how to rule the underworld and how to
invade the human world i am extremely
excited to learn more about the devils
and how
their society functions and if you are
also excited about this definitely drop
me a line
down in the comments finally i just want
to conclude the video by talking about
how
awesome noel is just look at this girl's
magic abilities and her battle technique
she has come so far since the beginning
of the story when she couldn't even
control her magic
and honestly her development is just as
impressive as osta's
but beyond the evolution of her powers i
also love the evolution of her character
and i love that she's not the type of
idealistic hero who wants to save
everyone
including brutally cruel villains noel
knows that innocent people will suffer
if she spares someone as evil and
unhinged as vanica
so noel is prepared to suck it up and do
what needs to be done
it's never an easy thing to do for a
heroic character but it is the right
choice
in this extreme case vanica wants to
wipe out like
80 percent of humanity she is not just
some petty criminal
so kudos to our girl noel for being a
true chadlas
okay now let me know what you guys think
what is going to happen next
with megikula is noel going to fight her
even though her spirit dive
is about to run out or is noelle maybe
going to use her
ultimate magic on megikula and even if
she does
will this ultimate magic be effective
against mkikula herself
vanica was one thing but if you've read
a bunch of manga and seen a bunch of
anime then you know that no one wants to
mess with a thousand year old
devil lolly this will not be an easy
task
although maybe austa will arrive in time
to help noel
in this fight i would love to see the
two of them fighting together and using
their swords together in battle but
whatever happens black clover has been
fired for a very long time
and with this sudden appearance of
megicula i am sure that the story is
only going to get more intense and even
better from here on out
if you enjoyed this blacklover video and
you want to see more you know what to do
just leave that like it takes a second
and it helps a lot and if you're new to
animeopro or maybe you watch our videos
but you haven't taken the time to
subscribe yet do me a favor and make
this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all
notifications you really have to go
through the trouble of subscribing
hitting that bell and then selecting the
option that says
all if you don't do that you're still
going to miss a ton of our videos
it's just how youtube works you can also
hit me up on twitter
and instagram at anime uproar
i want to give a big thank you to all of
our anime uproar patrons for making
videos like this one possible
special thank you to alpha sigma he's an
absolute mad lad
and disciple of lord twigo himself
and i can't forget all of our the one
tier patrons the ones who rise above
all other clans including ingrata pate
heffa algertol dr cortman the toasted
chi
the spike emperor otaku spidey life
tinnel tungsten tarkis
big buddhist cody hebert and monkey d
quilly and of course i want to thank
our pro hero to your patrons including
the one and only gilgamesh the red
haired raven angel cruz anatoly
kazatsuki very gucci alicia octor
bonnie parks hinokamian water joanne
garcia ted no ted
fat boy games corey mcgowan metal mama
deadly saint and soul ray slice and dice
if you enjoy our videos and you feel
that they provide value for you consider
supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patreon exclusive
discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these
amazing people as always thank you guys
so much for watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you